The joe rogan experience,
optimism weight about 10 pounds and then they told me he would never fight a one
85 again if I took the fight.
I mean one 70 again if I took the fight.
So he lost me sway,
still got the Tufts coaching job and on top of that he was going to get a
tighter shot.
Had it beaten me.
But why do you,
so you again,
it comes to this chip on your shoulder thing.
You feel like everybody's against,
you know you do a little,
I don't know.
You want me to though?
No,
you do.
This is what the,
what you're saying is the things that you're saying.
Yes.
I'm just saying that I know,
I know the,
I know the deck of cards I got and I know how to play these technical.
What do you think the deck of cards is?
The deck of cars is going to come a moment when I'm a superstar and when I get
to that moment,
I have more leverage at this time.
I'm not at the point where kind McGregor's at.
So I got,
if I got to fight the number one contender and I can't vouch how to fight at
George St Pierre or piss being or a con or a need at this moment,
I'm going to keep whooping ass until I get to that.
Well after George beaten right now,
George is in an amazing position,
right?
And George Beats Bisbing if he wanted it and he dropped the title.
But if you wanted to come back and fight you for uh,
the welterweight title,
that's a legitimate super fight right there.
I mean that makes a lot of sense.
Coming off of his big fight.
You don't think he does?
Look,
did you tell me,
you think Joe's wonderful.
Look at your faith.
George had these,
George,
she has to fight me before business.
He chose if I business well maybe you felt like that was a better fight for him
to come back with.
It was a definitely a better fight cause he,
it came back,
he gets me looking like that.
George would have been right back in retirement.
He did not look great.
Bismuth and did not look great.
Um,
one thing that helped George Nfi,
his experience,
he loosened up.
He was a little uptight,
you know,
I hadn't been an octagon what,
four years?
Almost a little over two or three.
Right.
It's more than that was it for,
it was almost four.
It wasn't quite far.
It's almost four cause I fought November,
I found November UFC,
there's a 25th anniversary.
I you're right.
I think it was like [inaudible].
Yeah,
okay.
That's a long ass time.
So he,
for him to not fight that long,
how much you train your ass in our fight fighting,
you'll have a training camp focus on a person.
It's tough.
So when he came back,
I saw the experience kicking.
He relax a little bit.
That's when he faked,
lended a left hook heading.
Not relaxed.
I mean,
you know,
who knows would've happened.
You know what I mean?
It was,
uh,
it was interesting because Bisping was tight and I expected,
I expected him to be looser.
Big business doesn't have the,
the,
I mean he's not guys out,
but he's not a guy that,
you know,
you're taking over like a rumble white or incontinence or myself or so one shot
Stephens,
Jeremy Stevens,
somebody that's going to touch you in this overweight.
So with that said,
he's a,
he's a person that's going to be volume.
He's going to be in your face,
great conditioning.
He's very durable.
And George had to make that adjustment.
He said,
all right,
and to be an athlete on this guy,
then we fake him out and then me get them thinking about the shot.
I took him down twice.
Let me get them thinking about it.
Level checks come up and foot,
very smart move.
And that's something,
the experience of being a champion.
Um,
a lot of them do.
Well,
there was some talk about him fighting Conor,
but I didn't hear any of that from the official people and him fighting Conor at
170 pounds would have been fascinating in terms of like,
it's a terrible matchup for Connor.
Yeah.
You know,
in terms of like just physicality.
Once again,
risk and reward.
What happens is the greatest welterweight of all time.
Yeah.
People going to torture him about it.
Mcconnell does.
WHATSAPP was another fight right now.
Like this is not a good time,
especially in his division.
There's so much talent.
Like right now.
He want to see he'll be right now.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I want to say are telling me.
I mean,
Tony's,
uh,
if,
if I was Connor,
which I'm not,
um,
if I had the pick the fight,
they're both are going to be,
I mean he'll be,
might be a bigger draw.
Cause you got a huge,
huge hundred and 47 million people in Russia might be a bigger draw,
but they both are very annoying fights.
Very dangerous fights.
Dangerous.
Tony Ferguson,
you know,
they don't take much for him to find a way to get around your neck and choking.
He's always get tired.
He doesn't get tired.
He looks like he's losing fights and he don't care.
He's striking is very awkward.
Um,
he can really do a Nadya's did to Conor and Nate Diaz no baffled.
I'm like,
damn,
I hit you with everything.
You still around.
They kind of will for the damn shot.
The same thing's gonna happen.
He do that to Tony.
Tony's gonna submit them.
Here's my prediction,
my prediction Conners and fight for a while.
He watched those two things to trip him.
They strip Connor and he comes by me,
Habib and Tony.
Fight for the world title for you.
I don't think either one of those guys are in the cars right now.
But for you,
what's your dream?
To be honest is,
um,
you know what my dream was to really,
I wanted to,
I wanted to find yours and as possible,
I felt like if I fall George,
I can legitimately say I'm the best welterweight of all time.
If I beat him,
it's still possible.
George hasn't retired.
He said anything about you?
He asked one time like Fox Q and a or he was gonna like,
so Tyrone,
if you fought,
what would be your game plan?
You know,
if you fought us,
but it got exed out because they didn't want to get all the fans pumped up that
we were fighting.
Why wouldn't they?
Do you think they're plotting against you?
It's here it is.
I see it in your face,
Joe.
He is not going to do,
I am too bright.
You want me to be like out the people who know me?
Listen,
I want you to just be focused.
You want me to be real?
Yeah,
for sure.
Let me real sure.
Do I think that the people want to see me lose?
No,
I don't think they want to see me little.
So I think that sometimes I'm a pain in the ass.
Yeah,
I am.
But in business,
at one point,
in any business,
there's not the person that's doing the business now what they best interests.
So if I'm an athlete and I'm looking out for my best interest,
and I'm trying to put myself in a position where you know,
I can fight,
become a legend,
become a hall of Famer,
I should do that.
If I want to be paid appropriately,
Yeah.